[Music]
would what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are on episode 99 with an
ting Shen hi thanks for coming on the
show
yeah thanks Alan yes I'm excited auntie
and I go back to what was it your
freshman year my sophomore year of high
school something like that something
like that so it's been like how long is
that eight years right I don't even know
is it nine ten nine years ten years yeah
something like that
oh my goodness yeah cuz that was fifteen
I'm twenty five ten years yeah yeah holy
cow
so that's when we first met and we were
doing a bunch of funny high school
league [ __ ] then like the late no like
debate debate and teenage Republican
silicon which now anything and I find
ourselves much more independent free
thinkers is that fair to say I think so
although people here still think I'm
conservative people in like South Dakota
think I'm liberal so I'm so happy that
you made it out to the Bay you went to
Berkeley did a master's in computer
science and electrical engineering and
then you pursued work in perception
systems for autonomous vehicles at deep
scale yeah exactly started by people in
my lab at Berkeley so my professor and
one of his PhD students Forrest and Ola
they started it so yeah I noticed that
Kurt who's your who's the advisor of the
lab he's now an adviser of the company
right he's a co-founder he's a
co-founder of the company cool cool yeah
so then the work did it come out of the
robot learning or they aspire lab or
which one out of the Aspire loud we were
spending a lot of like small neural
networks like compacting them down one
of the most like one of our famous
papers is called squeeze net when we
took Alex net which is like one of these
popular no networks blur image
location and we reduce the number of
parameters by like 500 X so what used to
be like hundreds of megabytes that
became half a megabyte so now we're
leveraging that technology of squeezing
their own networks to deploy deep
learning in autonomous vehicles okay so
so when the vehicle is proceeding its
environments taking a lot of data you
figured out how to squeeze that data
down to lower amounts know so there's
narrow networks that process all this
data mm-hm and usually neural networks
are very computationally expensive and
they require like big nvidia gpus and
tark's don't have those where most
trucks don't have those so we're trying
to figure out how to get those computer
vision algorithms to run on small n card
processors awesome ok so then the
external environment being processed
through computer vision on a smaller
processor via via and the neural
networks on a similar computer processor
so you figured out how to you guys were
figuring out at the Spier lab how to
crunch it down right ok and then that
seemed to be successful and then that
was like AHA this would work for
autonomous vehicles yeah although
there's like lots of different computer
vision neural network architectures so
we squeezed one no network that was for
image classification tells you like is
this image a cat or dog for example but
for driving situations there's a lot
more other algorithms like object
detection or like semantic segmentation
which is like figuring out exactly the
outlines of each vehicle were detecting
the death and all those algorithms they
usually have their own neural networks
and we applied the same principles to
squeeze them down so they all have their
own neural network so depth has its own
neural network and so does the outline
of the object normally and like academia
people like write a neural network for a
specific problem but obviously if you're
deploying in the car and you have all
these new networks you want to like
somehow combine them and have
sher computation so then it doesn't use
as much compute as having five neural
networks okay so so it does then do use
separate neural networks for the
different for depth or for the outside
of the vehicle or fur
well we combine them into a single you
combine them into single one huh okay
yeah it's a normally for classification
it would be just a single object but
because you're doing it in a computer
vision trying to analyze the whole
environment then you bring in all the
different variables into one right
there's just a lot of different computer
vision tasks that need to be done
yeah damn okay so what does this spiral
abnormally work on so the Aspire life
has a history of parallel computing and
just computational efficiency cool so I
joked that the lab usually just takes
whatever is popular now and makes it way
faster so when I was out of the lab the
popular thing was like AI and yeah and
that word yeah so it still is isn't it
maybe it still is a blockchain or
quantum computing is down there maybe a
spire love I think got renamed to like
the rise lab which has something else
that I don't remember something with
security but probably a lot of AI still
so okay so then as you figure out this
process and you begin to apply it to
autonomous vehicles this has been about
two years or two and a half years how
long has deep scale around yeah well for
us and Kurt they started working on deep
scale probably in like 2015 ish or maybe
even earlier than that but obviously the
with all startups you do a lot of
customer exploration yep and then you
find the application so has changed over
time so I don't think there's like a
solid start date when we first got
funding was probably like 2016 and
that's when they were able to bring you
on board and yep other people on board
okay so all right I have one I want to
take this a couple ways I wonder if we
should start with let's start with some
of the what start with some of the
technical stuff and then I and then I
want to get to some of the vision stuff
yeah because you're already the
visionary stuff because you're already
in pilots with OEMs right yeah yeah
which is really exciting because then
you're actually putting your software to
the test right yeah but you're not
designing any hardware you're not we're
not building any large you're using
existing hardware yeah okay so now let's
go through that what is the existing
hardware that you're using so hardware
for neural networks usually people use
NVIDIA GPUs yep
NVIDIA has tried making smaller GPUs
like they're like TX ones those smaller
GPUs and there may I'd like to try px
platform that's specifically designed
for autonomous driving scenarios and I
think there in a couple of Tesla cars
but those GPUs are still really big din
power-hungry and pretty expensive so
where you work with a lot even smaller
cheap GPUs on that like arm CPUs with
accelerators for example so it would be
stuff like tea eyes TDA 2x or some
Renaissance or NXT processors and it
makes that
yeah those companies like Ti and XP and
Renaissance so those are the companies
yes yeah you don't hear about them
because they make like autonomous ships
with like Nvidia is like 1% of the
processor market in cars in cars and
these are like the big players TI and DX
and XP and XP yeah huh at least I might
conductor companies merge all the time
so yeah it's easy to get their names
confused but yeah ok Ti is in Texas
Instruments yep ah yeah interesting
you know last time ever we're hearing oh
yeah oh great so they actually make
processors ya know made processors
interest
for Thomas vehicles yeah or just for
vehicles in general like your car
probably has processors from these
companies and so now they're prot ok
soon let's go through a couple things
here so the first is that the processor
that they're not putting into the
vehicle it we're trying to make sure
that it's not going to be sucking a lot
of the power from the car to perceive
the environment and to make the analysis
right you'll usually I think it mostly
comes down to cost power is an issue
when you get to like because like
cooling 200 watts yeah kind of annoying
but mostly it's for cost reasons and
also these processor already like
automotive grade and they've been
certified these guys have been in the
automotive industry for decades so
rather than maybe paying an extra
$10,000 for your car to be autonomous
you might want to bring that cost down
only two or three thousand more dollars
for it to be autonomous yeah I would say
so should like that well so this is like
one side of it deep steel where Sun and
it's like lowering cost but then we're
also building technology that enables
the l4 l5 cars where you might not care
about cost as much
what's l4 l5 car so there's like five
levels of autonomous driving I remember
learning about this a little bit ago
yeah okay yeah give refresher yeah the
way I like to think of it is like so
like l2 is where you can take your feet
off so this is like adaptive cruise
control for example like where's l1 is
just regular cruise control and then l3
is you can take your hands off the
steering wheel and it does Lane keeping
and so uh we still have to pay attention
to the car yep and l4 I think of as you
can take your eyes off the road or you
don't have to pay attention and if the
cars like I'm about to enter an area
that I don't know how to drive please
take over then you start paying
attention so right now for example
Tesla's technology is that like l3 real
oh yeah because you have beeps that you
Amy do we have to do we have to
constantly pay attention yes
as an l5 I think it was you just turn
your brain off and they're just exactly
sleep yeah yeah it's not good huh that's
good I like okay so you're we you said
you guys were also working on l4 l5
technology right okay so we work on some
l4 l5 technology but then we can also
take that analogy squeeze it down bring
it to the o2 o3 market okay yeah okay so
in the in the process of working on l4
l5 technology what does that look like a
deep scale what do you mean by that so
like what would what would it look like
for you to make the software that's
needed for the human to be able to be on
their phone or on a magazine or whatever
whoever uses magazines but huh to be
doing whatever they want in the car and
then to get a notification from the car
hey can you pay attention now I'm about
to go through this area or to even be
sleeping how do you build out that
system so we only build a very small
portion of that system so usually for
these l4 l5 systems there's sensing and
there's perception there's like
high-definition maps that no it's
actually where all the lanes are in
every street and though where your car
is and controls to actually figure out
where how the car should behave and then
there's like actuation that actually
moves a car so we only work on
perception so taking the data from
sensors understanding that environment
but we don't make the decisions on what
to do okay yeah so so then so then the
the sensors themselves have their limits
and you're in there there's other people
working on the sensors and then making
the sensors better you take the best
sensors and you have your software they
look use the sensor technology to take
in the data then you crunch the data in
efficient ways process it and then you
that's your that's what deep scale does
and then it sends that signal to the
actuators that actually makes a movement
yeah it sends it to a control system
that has to make these decisions that's
like we say there's a car in front of
you the control system has to figure out
do I wait behind this car do I go around
them yeah yeah yeah
okay so now let's do some of the more
okay so let's you
one more time is you're both working on
decreasing the cost with on the on the
hardware side of things with the
hardware players to bring it down to
hopefully a couple thousand bucks per
car or so we're trying to enable butter
l2 l3 features yeah for way less than
thousands of dollars exactly for example
right now a lot of cars have like
emergency braking yeah a lot of them do
it based on a radar and sly radar in
front of the car a caesar car and then
it breaks but radar doesn't really work
on pedestrians for example hmm you
really need to have a radar and a camera
so that you can see the pedestrian
coming up so these systems right now I
feel like people tend to just like check
like emergency braking done but they
could definitely be improved a lot
because there's no it doesn't work for
humans unless there's a camera right on
radar won't work for you okay now okay
now quick so that's that's one side the
other side is is working on the l4 l5
technology side of things okay now on
the sensing technology that you're using
mhm
what is the sensing technology that
you're saying can we list all the
different ones because there's too many
in the first place there's like radar
lidar then there's camera camera yeah
what yeah what else
and maybe ultrasound and ultrasound okay
so that's the your cars parking sensors
I like beeps at you that's ultrasound
oh it's sending a little sound it's the
sound wave is out of this yeah I think I
think so and then watching them in like
high school there's a little distance
that's where you turn that to Ti
calculators and oh yeah yeah yeah it's
like those things in your car that's
right and there's an ultrasound on all
the a lot of the first robotics robots
yeah exactly what yeah yeah okay so okay
so radar uses infrared the uses like
radar radar so it uses radar wave which
is the microwave left
frequency it's in okay but it's below
the visible light a spectrum right
it's longer wave right I think radar
yeah I think it is okay longer leave and
then lidar is light radar yeah so so
it's using light pulses and then it's
reflecting back and capturing it right
okay so and that's the ones that spin
uncontrollably those are the light ours
yeah okay so there's also have lighters
that don't spin but light ours a don't
spit because then they just stay and
shoot and shoot and shoot and shoot but
they don't know sometimes they have like
micro mirrors and then they use this
allows to scan okay yeah
okay so then so then as so then as let's
say as a spinning a NASA shoots the
light it reflects off of the surface it
comes back and then it senses the depth
of that along that took the light to
come by how long there's not time and
then it has to do that for every single
like couple centimeters basically or a
couple inches or what however yeah and
that's that's a lot of sensing that it's
got to do and then a lot of processing
okay so then usually I think it's like
maybe fires twenty thousand times since
I've been there twenty thousand a second
yeah Wow okay and then there's camera
yep now do you guys work with camera yes
that's probably our main one okay yeah
okay so all right so now if it seemed
all right 15 minutes timer let's go
power round thank you Ron all right so
okay now let's do this
so camera is we're currently looking at
cameras we're using cameras let's say
we're using our smartphone camera we're
pointing right now let's say the camera
is being pointed at us okay the cameras
being pointed at us with the camera
let's say the middle camera yeah as it's
doing that how are you how do you just
your software recognize where we are at
how far away we are
yeah yeah so this is after detection
which is deep learning based so a neural
network takes the image as input and it
outputs the locations of each objects
that you want to recognize how does it
get the depth sensing
so Deb sensing there's a bunch of
different ways to do it so one way
there's like traditional computer vision
algorithms that take two cameras and
then do like stereo matching to find the
duck there's another way where you find
detect the person or car and then use
some other sensor to get the depth or
the third ways it's like you learn it
through the neural network for example
if you cover up one of your eyes you can
still tell how far away things are hmm
and knowing that we're stable to learn
that as well okay so because I know that
were it's so it's it's really tough
first of all to make the understanding
of neural networks relatable in lay
terms it's tough I'm I'm gonna try and
have forests back on the show or you on
the show
in the next couple of months hopefully
when you guys are visiting and stuff SF
and we'll try and unpack a very simple
way to understand neural networks yeah
that'd be great I think yeah I've seen a
couple of pretty good explanations that
everyone can understand good okay so
we'll do that in four but for the end of
this show what we'll do is we'll talk
about the current let's go back to this
so we had L 0 to L five Tesla's
currently around L 2 to L 3 your can can
you speak on who's using deep scale
thing right now we're focusing on l2 l3
in terms of who's using deep scale and
there's the company alive is just vital
lays down the road
can you and then can you tell us which
companies or not yet uh so one
partnership we announces with hala liya
very Allah yeah they're actually called
hella so there's a lot of jokes that
they are they in California where
they're in Germany they're Germany yeah
so I think how was like a family name or
something yeah but no no it's just we
just make jokes about yeah
yeah so they're using your software now
in German technology yeah so we've just
we made a partnership with them to
develop this technology because they're
a Tier one suppliers they supply - oh
yeah okay they supply to OEM yep
okay so then there OMS will purchase
from hallo who is now purchasing your
software to add to their sensor system
yes okay okay now I'm sure that this is
talked about a lot what are your
thoughts about the trolley problem yes
so I'm just just clarify here you have
the chance of either the autonomous
vehicle will either hit one person and
injured one person or swerve to the side
and injure five people how does one
program make these decisions so no one
programs solutions to the trolley
problem because they're far from smart
enough to understand it and I'd like not
a thing people programming a
self-driving car to worry about like
they program if you see person don't hit
person and then they feel like if you
see person don't have person so and then
if other option is hit five people then
why it doesn't evaluate like option it's
just like like they're these algorithms
are too dumb to understand ethics or
morality and it's not a thing that
people think about anything for now for
now yeah for now okay what do you what
are your thoughts about the displacement
of about you know there's three million
or so drivers in the US truck car taxi
but but there's also plenty of jobs for
example deep scale now has a team of
whatever 20 people 12 people some like
that when a 20-ish
so so you've hired there's 20 new jobs
right so so there are new jobs coming in
as there are jobs taken away so what are
your thoughts about what's gonna happen
with that and also how to retrain etc
mmm yeah I don't think I think about the
jobs as much since we're right now we're
mostly focused on making cars less
profitable and increasing the safety
working on like l2 l3 systems that just
like save lives and they're not react
displacing jobs right now so yeah that's
not something that we're actively
worrying about at the moment yeah but in
the future I think it would be like
anything else in the past has displayed
jobs all the automation in any other
sectors that we've seen I think people
will probably switch over to more
services or into jobs but that's just my
guess I don't think I thought about it
enough and it like you said you're
focused on saving lives in this l2 l3
category right now that the person is
maybe losing their focus from the
vehicle the vehicles actually more
focused on the road and perceiving its
environment than even the human is
there's so many instances of humans
visit 1.25 million accidents or deaths
per year across the world like that
yeah that's wow that's so many yeah if
the perception systems for autonomous
vehicles can help us decrease that
amount of deaths that's fantastic okay
how about we ask you
but what are your thoughts about the
autonomous vehicle economy that's kind
of gonna start happening where I
purchase an autonomous vehicle for
whatever forty thousand dollars and then
I just let it go and make me money and
as a decentralized entity that goes and
makes money yeah yeah so it will
definitely see well this is pretty far
down the road I think so yeah like ten
years old yeah yeah in like maybe ten
years we'll definitely see a lot of
autonomous taxi fleets and I think
people will still want to own cars
it'll still be people that want to own
cars but a lot fewer and yeah I think
what you said you can rent out your
self-driving cars for other people to
use I see that happening yeah
how about what are your thoughts because
we touched a little bit on the ethics of
like the trolley problem you're like
we're nowhere near that it's so dumb I
can't even it's just trying to recognize
whatever so it's like one sees a person
and it hits like some line in the code
that says if see person apply brakes
great yeah and then it does that yeah
okay so there it's so that's that now
what about the or do you have do you
have let's go another let's go ten years
down the line again okay so I'm getting
into an autonomous vehicle let's say
that this media company simulation does
great things and is then you know
whatever ten million subs and we're
doing lots of great stuff and there's
some other media company that is also at
you know ten million subs and the US is
a competitor yeah so how does my safety
how do I make sure that I'm safe when I
enter this autonomous vehicle that I
have no control over driving yes
so like autonomous vehicle security like
is an issue and I think people do need
to spend a good amount of effort on that
because like if someone like hacks into
a Economist virtual network that's way
more devastating than like any other
terrorist attack for example so I think
definitely people need to take
autonomous mutual safety the security
yes seriously yeah I think I'm sure
there's people working on that yeah we
need people like you guys at Deep scale
to also be like hey it's really
important like with your voices as well
yeah that's why we bring you onto the
show we get you guys to talk about what
you're doing and the importance of these
things but then also you talk to all
your big guys that you talk to about hey
the safety and security these things is
important like you said it'd be so much
more devastating because you can
actually silo out individual attacks on
to people yeah so like even now the
technology a lot of cars you can like
start them from the internet for example
and have them like back out of their
parking spot
so securing those things now is good
practice for the future yeah yeah we're
we're getting we're getting there um
it's crazy because when we were in when
we were in high school it's so funny
that nobody was we didn't know what
neural networks were we didn't know what
we had no idea about the robot in AI age
that we were entering no one in high
school was teaching us about AI and
robots and we were that was 2006 2010
ish but nobody was teaching us about
that same day I really the nerd deep
learning to Catholic and 2012 ish and
yeah and just made every algorithm so
much better it's taking over all the
classical algorithms and now the
question is our if we look back at
Roosevelt High School in Sioux Falls
South Dakota are the kids being taught
about AI and robots now that's the
question because even though we weren't
taught that when it wasn't popular no it
is popular are the kids learning about
it now I don't know about if they're
learning about it in school the like
surely see it on the internet Lee if
they watch this channel they probably
learned a lot about it I hope that they
are learning about it in school I hope
schools are teaching AI and robotics I
hope they're teaching biotech and
decentralisation technologies like
blockchain I really hope so because you
got to get kids prepared for the new era
of the tech explosion because long gone
are the people that want to do
repetitive service
or retail industry jobs by the time they
get there especially kids that are born
like today Wow okay how about we asked
you a couple of these quick simulation
questions I actually just learned about
this recently from Jionni who were gonna
have on the show in about a month in
June he's one of the major communicators
of transitioning like Shell and BP and
other oil and gas companies to
electrification yeah so he said that
there's 50 electric vehicle companies in
China yes and and so yeah they
apparently in Shenzhen they unleashed an
electric bus fleet yeah that was like
there's 18,000 buses or something like
that I was like wow that is crazy that
already happened yep yeah I think China
is definitely taking a lead on
electrification and tackling climate
change which is a weird shift but hey
I'm glad they are there yeah yeah yeah
they also have like way worse pollution
problems which is why people care about
that a lot more than here because you'd
like freeze the problem every day so
then you're really motivated to push for
these kind of projects okay so then the
this question is about globalization how
does the u.s. work with China on
figuring out how to best move forward on
which area on everything from autonomous
industries to to even things like gee
apology of politics and geo-economics
around these topics how do we move
forward how do you think is best to move
forward working together learning
there's already decent amount of
collaboration among like private
companies like there's a lot of Chinese
for our companies I have labs and
Silicon Valley
but on like a bigger government steel
I'm not sure if there's a lot of
uncertainty with how the government's
will play you a lot
get along with each other so does that
uncertainty ever kind of like rub you in
a way that you're like huh maybe we
should talk about this and figure it out
um maybe I think each each country can
push along with its own progress and I
think there's like all the collaboration
between the countries in terms of like
technology is already happening so I'm
not sure how much extra value there is
to Lightroom's maintain their dream and
say we should do these tools like that
does help all the countries more
accountable but each country needs to be
motivated to meet those goals - yeah do
you think we're alone in the cosmos no
do you think advanced civilizations are
roaming the cosmos
possibly
you answered no so what do you think
they look like
probably either I'm guessing you
probably look like earth like ten
million years ago or something like that
so you think the it's still back from
the evolutionary spectrum the other one
maybe okay well it's just it's very
likely that it's not at the same spot in
the evolutionary spectrum like either
way behind your way ahead yeah yeah do
you think we're in a computer simulation
no you see this is base reality yeah
okay well I mean like I do you can't
know so that's just what I chose to X
left okay and two more quick questions
what's the deepest emotion you've ever
felt defined deepest well what's the
most profound emotion you've ever felt I
think I usually just feel like a lot of
joy and I think even though it's like a
basic emotion I think that's the good
one
look at this smile it's over it's over
it's so much and last question is what
do you think's the most beautiful thing
in the world
those feel the whole thing in the world
totally just everyone working together
and solving problems yeah
painting this has been such a pleasure
thank you for coming up Thank You Alan
this has been such a pleasure everyone
thanks so much for tuning in if you guys
had a good time share the content with
other people let's get more people
talking about autonomous vehicles
perception systems for them what it
means like to either have a camera or
lidar and how you crunch in all of that
data thank you to deep scale for doing
that crunching and figuring it all out
we need more people like you and we're
hiring deep skills hiring links of bio
check it out in the comments let us know
your thoughts we would love to feature
your comments on Twitter and Instagram
so do comment subscribe join us in the
movement we'd love to have you and help
support us on patreon we need to keep
this sustainable we need to grow grow
grow we got a lot of goals ahead of us
to hit so we need your help and joining
the movement thank you very much
everyone and we'll see you later today
with Bernard Gunther much
of peace
[Music]